[Music]
no
God no God please no no
no what up peeps I'm Dave rubben this is
the Ruben report it is January 30th 2024
we're live streaming on Rumble YouTube
and locals and I believe Instagram for
five minutes and then you can jump over
and watch on the other platforms if
you'd like we've got a postgame show as
always Ruben report. locals.com if you
want to correct me question me poke andr
me whatever you might want to do that's
where we do all of that sort of stuff uh
the theme of today's show is there's an
awful lot happening in the world right
now uh this w a 3 situation seems like
it's ramping up a bit I'm going to try
to cool the Jets as everyone loves
talking about oh my God World War II is
happening and oh my God the Civil War is
happening and oh my God the alien
invasion is happening sometimes maybe we
can have some calmer heads prevail so
we'll do a little bit of that uh but
what I wanted to start with that'll kind
of frame everything is that uh John
Stewart uh I guess former comedian I
don't know what we call him at this
point now he's basically a progressive
activist now uh he is returning to the
Daily Show you know John Stewart hosted
The Daily Show for I don't know almost
20 years or so some of you may know this
I was an intern at The Daily Show in
1999 right when John Stewart took over
from uh for Craig kilborne who was a
former ESPN guy uh maybe I'll tell you a
bit more about that later but in any
event John Stewart left The Daily Show
what was it about six years or so ago
ends up bringing a new show the problem
with John Stewart onto Apple TV uh and
he just goes all in on the leftism but
the machine is bringing him back now
putting him back at The Daily Show uh at
the chair on a weekly show not a Daily
Show so The Daily Show is going weekly
all right they're going to struggle with
that and we're going to talk about how
that sort of thing leads to a lot of the
cultural rot when we just sort of
retread all of these people so let's
just get to it tweet from the post
millennial breaking John Stewart returns
as The Daily Show host ahead of the
2024 election and uh CBS News is very
excited that John Stewart will be giving
young people their news once again had a
familiar face is returning to late night
TV John Stewart is coming back as host
and executive producer of The Daily Show
at least on a temporary basis Stuart
will be be behind the desk every Monday
starting on February 12th through the
2024 presidential election Comedy
Central set a rotating lineup of
correspondents will sit in for Stuart
during the rest of the week Comedy
Central is owned by Paramount global the
parent company of CBS News welcome back
John we're doing PR we're owned by the
same people and we have to tell you he's
really great yeah okay uh so you guys
get how the whole machine works right
there's no reason for CBS News to be
covering that on their Nightly News
program but he's back they're all in on
it together you can see how the machine
operates this way and the damn shame
about John Stewart and we we'll
illustrate this in just a moment is that
at least for the first couple years of
The Daily Show he was doing something
kind of new and sming and prodding at
the media the way I kind of do on this
show uh and I did kind of like him he
sort of has gone off the deep Ender I
don't even need to qualify that he has
completely gone off the deep end when it
comes to Progressive politics and and I
would say become everything that he
probably wants uh despised his show that
he uh that was cancelled the problem
with John Stewart which was on Apple TV
they only shot 20 episodes of it he made
$24
million for 20 episodes I just want to
be clear I'm not making that kind of
money on this show uh and if I was oh
man what we'd be eating for lunch uh
anyway let's just uh roll back in time
for just a bit and show you a little bit
of this type of woke nonsense that he
has pushed on America over the years uh
here he is on this problem show going
after the Arkansas attorney general
Leslie rutage over child genital
mutilation why would the state of of
Arkansas step in to
override parents Physicians
psychiatrists
endocrinologists who have developed
guidelines why would you override those
guidelines well I think it's important
that all of those Physicians all of
those experts for every single one of
them there's an expert that says we
don't need to allow children to be able
to take those medications that there are
many instances where but you know that's
not true you know it's not for everyone
there's one there's these are the
established well I don't know that
that's not true I don't know that then
why would you why would you pass a law
then if you don't if you don't know that
that's true wouldn't you well I know
that there are doctors and that we had
plenty of people come and testify before
our legislature who said that uh you
know we have 98% of the young people who
have gender dysphoria right are that
they are able to move move past that and
once they have the the help that they
need no longer suffer from gender
dysphoria 98% without that medical
treatment that's that's an incredibly
madeup figure that's that doesn't
comport with any of the studies or
documentation that exists from these
medical organizations what what Medical
Association are you talking about of
these doctors well we have all of that
in our uh legislative history and we'll
be glad to provide that to you I I don't
had the name of that off the top of my
head I know it's something that you
don't have the name of the
organization that that you're top my
head oh okay but yes we have all of that
sided in all of our briefs you're
suggesting that protecting children
means overriding the recommendations of
the American Medical Association the
American Association of
Pediatrics I mean it goes on and on what
an absolutely smug unlikable person he
became for the cool one 1 million plus
per episode he was making on that now
defunct show so then the machine brings
him back owned by
Viacom um you might want to read uh
maybe John Stewart if you're watching
this you might want to read irreversible
damage uh by abigael shrier thank you uh
who wrote an incredible book about how
so much of what's happening to our
children is a social contagion
particularly when it comes to young
girls thinking they can transition and
become young boys now this that clip was
from a couple years ago but we know how
much of this has ruined young people's
lives like why is John Stewart so smug
about chemically castrating children
that the state would be a little
concerned about that about drugging
children so that they can't go through
puberty and everything else but this is
what the left has pushed on us and John
Stewart was sort of put out there as the
respectable face of all of this and then
of course what happens is you get all of
these bad policies you literally are
going after children that woman you
think she's a bad woman the attorney
general there you think she's a bad
woman or she's just trying to protect
children because no you cannot take a
boy and actually make them a girl that's
just not reality right uh but then what
happens is not only do they get all the
bad policies pushed through because of
people like John Stewart these media
people who confuse you and guilt you and
go after the good guys and make it seem
like they're bad or make it seem like if
you care about a border you're racist
and everything else they then tacitly
support all of the bad politicians uh I
think we showed you this clip once from
about a year ago this is JN Stewart
interviewing Gavin Nome and you can see
again he does this sort of duplicitous
thing where you think he's kind of being
good and well take a look here here's
the problem that you run up against is
in that reimagining you run up against
political reality simple things like
instead of giving them $200 when they
walk out the gate giving them $1,000
when they walk out the gate and you guys
couldn't couldn't do that politically
you vetoed that because I imagine you
had to yeah well combination that and we
should have done it through the budget
process by the way do I not only know
the realities that that person that
killed that police officer the district
attorney accused me being responsible
that's right for that I live the
realities I don't know them it's not
intellectual living them sure and that
puts you on your heels no didn't put me
on he actually put me on my toes right
you want reform and you want to be
Progressive I want Public Safety I want
real Public Safety I want people to feel
safe it's about your own self-interest
right you want to make sure your kids
are safe you're safe you don't have to
turn your head when you're getting the
ATM machine uh ABS fundamentally lutely
that's the core there you can see I
don't have to talk about uh Gavin
Newsome there I think I made my feelings
about him clear yesterday in case you
weren't sure what my feelings are but
Stuart you want reform you want to be
Progressive like he's running cover for
a guy that has Unleashed hell on the
streets of California and caused the
mass fleeing and the Urban Decay and
everything else so again he's trying to
take out people who are protecting
children children he's propping up the
bad politicians that is what he decided
to do with his career which again 20
years ago when he was starting The Daily
Show he was not a leftist nutbag he's
another one of these people that just
went along for the ride and now runs
cover for the machine I want to show you
a bit about what has happened I know
that people don't really watch The Daily
Show anymore but it's an interesting
just it's an interesting cultural touch
point I would say to see what has
happened at The Daily Show since he has
left you might remember uh during our
summer of love when BLM black lives
matter and antifa were burning down the
country you remember that it wasn't too
long ago I know we memory Hall things uh
and actor Terry Cruz was critical of BLM
and then all hell broke loose and he was
they were going to try to cancel him and
kick kick him out of Hollywood and
everything else so he was basically
forced by his agents who knows who who
pushed him there to go on The Daily Show
to have a struggle session with
Progressive activist Trevor Noah my
thing is I just just
wanted peace and I guess I it goes back
to my approval yes it goes back to my
need for approval it went back to that
um and again it was a mistake it was it
was a mistake to tweet that out at that
time that was that was the thing funny
enough because you know Martin Luther
King Jr has talked about black Supremacy
Nelson Mandela himself was one of the
people who said I do not look for the
oppression of white people I don't look
for the oppression of black people I
don't want anybody to be oppressed
that's right right but the timing I
think was the issue you know what I mean
I say that in the book yeah you were
going that's not what I was trying to do
and I think you know this is one of
those moments where I was like that's
why books over tweets it is no it is
that oh oh God you're so terrible so you
have to come on our show and apologize
because you basically said that uh all
people are created equal and we
shouldn't be burning down stores in the
name of equality and diversity and
Equity it's like it's just it's so evil
and that Trevor Noah who's just awful
sits there here here's a this is this is
a gem so Trevor Noah who also no longer
is the host of The Daily Show then they
basically fired him although they didn't
call it firing because they would be
afraid of saying we fired a black guy
they were like ah he's moving on but he
was fired because nobody was watching
the show uh here he is being lectured by
a dude who thinks he's a chick and
taking it like a woman there are many
elements to what you said which I
appreciate so let's try break them
down one thing that confus us uses me
personally is it it it seems like we
have discussions about who should
participate in which category and how
you know on the face of it it seems
simple as you say you know if somebody
identifies as a woman if they
transgender they can compete against
women who were born biologically and and
then if not then not but then there are
many who would argue who are not
transphobes there are many who born
biologically women who will say but you
have an unnatural advantage over me and
that makes the sport unfair how do you
how do you respond to that yeah there's
lots of ways you can respond to that so
the first is the the very language of
you were born and I'm not biological
somehow like I don't think I'm a cyborg
so like this idea that like oh you're
not a biological woman well I am a woman
that's a fact I am female so all my
identity records my racing license my
medical records I'll say female right
and I'm pretty sure I made of biological
stuff so I'm a biological female as well
so this question of do trans women have
an advantage over CIS women we don't
know um in fact there's basically no
published research on this question
however uh there's good reason to think
that there isn't but I think it's
irrelevant isn't it really great
watching those two clips back toback so
first you have him forcing Terry Cruz to
have a struggle sessions Terry Cruz has
to basically be like saying I'm I'm not
racist somehow something like that
please please forgive me let me back in
the club and then there is Trevor Noah
sitting across from that creature who's
telling you that he or she is is not a
cyborg yes you are biological we all
understand that but you're biologically
a dude and you are dressing up as a girl
so that you can beat other girls in
sports and he has to just sit there he
just sits there and takes it now the
reason I'm showing you all this and
starting the show with this John Stewart
thing and everything else is because the
Daily Show became that cultural touch
Point more young people get their news
from The Daily Show than anywhere else
right so when you wonder how did this
all happen that so many kids are
confused about their gender how did it
happen that being not racist actually
makes you racist it's because this is
the crap that Hollywood pushes on us and
by the way it's owned by Viacom that
also owns CBS News I'm shocked and
appalled anyway Trevor Noah ultimately
gets fired but they don't call it a
firing because he's black as I just said
uh and they've brought in a series of
guest host John Leguizamo who's a pretty
decent actor actually he's kind of a fun
fun actor I I enjoy some of his stuff uh
he was a guest host one of the days and
here he is lecturing on why we should
smuggle migrants across the border but
the truth is undocumented immigrants are
mostly filling jobs that Americans have
no interest in doing I mean are you
going to tell me there are Americans
just lining up wishing they could pick
vegetables in the sun all the live long
day America's a trip
man first you didn't want to do any of
the field work and now you want to do
all the field
work make up your goddamn mind all right
putting aside that it's not funny I mean
again it's it's actually racist like
he's actually being racist and and even
put even if he wasn't being
racist illegal people are here illegally
even if there are jobs for them then
what you do is you have them come
legally and you figure it out right so
we've got at least we thought it was
about 12 million illegals in this
country but now we know 6 million have
come in the last three years so let's
say we have closer to 15 to 18 million
in this country already the Border being
ransacked every freaking day we have
this pathetic uh ridiculous bipartisan
Congressional deal that if the
Republicans sign on to it's it's just
absolute death for the party that will
allow 5,000 illegals to come a day on
top of the legals which is 1.8 million
people a year illegally that we'd let in
which makes no sense why are we letting
illegals in why are we literally signing
something says oh people can break this
law makes no sense but this is what the
corporate media pushes on us so they are
bringing John Stewart back to run cover
probably for that slick haired Gavin
Newsome guy as they bring him back too
because we all know Joe Biden is
breaking down anyway I'm going to
connect all that to a whole bunch other
stuff but let's talk about tax Network
USA guys are you struggling with your
back taxes or your unified returns un
Returns the IRS is escalating
collections adding 20,000 new agents and
sending over 5 million collection
letters to kickoff 24 in these
challenging times your best defense is
tax Network USA don't let the IRS take
advantage of you with over 14 years of
tax experience tax Network USA has saved
their clients over a billion in back
taxes no matter the size of your tax
issue their expertise is your advantage
they specialize in negotiating with the
IRS aiming to significantly reduce your
debt tax Network USA doesn't just negot
apprciate they also protect your assets
from the IRS seizures and manage your
yearly returns for ongoing compliance
importantly they are licensed to help
with all state tax issues regardless of
where you live in the US the clock is
ticking don't wait as the IRS steps up
its game seize control of your financial
future now contact tax Network USA for
immediate relief and expert guidance
call 1800 24560 or visit TN usa.com Dave
don't let tax issues overpower you tune
in to tax Network USA and find your your
path to financial peace of mind and now
back to me okay so you might be going
Dave I don't really care for the Daily
Show never really watch The Daily Show
you know we get it these comedians all
suck blah blah blah what I'm trying to
lay out to you and that's all well and
good is that all of the ideas that we
just talked about there are the things
that get into the culture and then you
wonder why everything's wrong why our
politicians suck why we don't know up is
down and up is up and down is down and
all of these things so now I want to
drive this a little further into the
into the cultural piece of all of this
uh because Law and Order which has been
on the air for like 880,000 years at
this point uh there is a clip going
around of a new episode of Law and Order
where a white woman is raped by a black
man but doesn't want him to go to jail
take a look at
this but Natalie Jay Watson raped
you you think I
forgot how could I this entire trial has
been an exercise in reminding me and
this is your chance to do something
about it I am going to believe me
because I can I can afford therapy I
have that luxury and maybe one
day I'll be
okay but if that
teenager goes to
prison he may not
be
ever
I don't want
that Natalie
wait can we uh can we do a road trip
would you guys be interested in doing a
road trip after the show drive cross
country go to Hollywood bomb the
place what the high hell are these
people doing that do you realize how
absolutely insane that is do you know
what rape is you guys know what rape is
right um it's not a good thing but that
woman well I'm in essence I I'm white
I'm white I've got a little cash I'll
have I'll go to therapy I'll drink a
pumpkin spice latte I'll be just fine
but that poor black kid who raped me we
wouldn't want to screw up his life they
are so the messaging they are
sending to the brains of young people
and I guess I guess middle-aged people
who watch law and order it everything is
freaking backwards they have taken art
and made it activism speaking of which
there's a new Snow White coming out
because you know they can't make
anything new they just have to ruin
the old things and actress Rachel zler
who plays Snow White she's very excited
because this ain't going to be that
1937 Snow White bigot racist homophobe
transphobe stuff you said you were
bringing a Modern Edge to it on stage
what do you mean by that I just mean
that it's no longer
1937 and we absolutely wrote a snow
white that is not going to be saved by
the prince she's not going to be saved
by The Prince and she's not going to be
dreaming about true love she's dreaming
about becoming the leader she knows she
can be and the leader that her late
father told her that she could be if she
was Fearless Fair Brave and true and so
it's just a really incredible story for
I think young people everywhere to see
themselves in Snow White is running for
president I'm launching my campaign it's
totally incredible it's going to be like
a completely different story I don't
even know why we're calling it Snow
White how did I even get this job what
am I doing here what are you doing here
what uh I do want to back up for just a
second uh I don't uh condone uh or call
for terrorism in Hollywood or anywhere
else I didn't mean bomb the place I
meant like I meant like glitter bombit
you know what I mean just go there and
pour glitter all over these people that
that is what I meant uh let's just be
clear about that because Media Matters
I'm sure is watching every moment of
this Ruben just called to bomb Hollywood
um but you see this they destroy
absolutely everything thing and speaking
of things that they've destroyed it's
not just old things like uh Snow White
from 1937 uh it's things that are uh
have been important over the last couple
decades like Saturday Night Live which
used to be a comedy show uh here's a
little diddly they did this weekend
mocking Trump and if you can find the
comedy I'll give you a shiny nickel
hasn't lost a step Trump did have a
slight stumble this week while talking
about Banks and he introduced an
interesting new term called debank we're
also going to place strong protections
to stop Banks and Regulators from trying
to debank you they want to debank you
and we're going to
debank I don't know what the hell dbank
means but he might have to take D
ambulance to see the doctor
yeah okay not funny but putting aside
again the not funny thing it's what
they're talking about that's really the
issue you don't know what de banking is
do you know that Nigel farage uh one of
the most popular politicians in all of
the UK has been debanked his Bank closed
his accounts and said we will not do
business with you because we don't like
your politics uh de banking another way
that you can be debanked is when they
freeze your bank accounts like they did
to the Canadian truckers but he's never
heard of that we don't know anything
about the con the the we wouldn't know
anything anything about how this happens
or what's going on here like this is
just absolutely terrible but again I'm
showing you just the cultural rot that
these people put out and then you'll
wonder why our politicians suck and why
we have people rampaging through the
border and nobody to do anything about
it but we will do uh some more coverage
of all of that stuff after I talk to you
guys about the wellness company guys
recent clusters of respiratory illnesses
in northern China alongside outbreaks of
what's being referred to as white lung
syndrome in the United States or
scattered across headlines right now
drawing attention to the importance of
being prepared for medical emergencies
with close to 90% of pharmaceuticals in
the US being produced outside of the
country what happens when the next
Global crisis strikes countries clamp
down on exports they stockpile the price
of drugs rise and the pharmacy shelves
in America become empty and this is
already starting to happen you guys have
heard me talk about the wellness company
before but when we're staring down the
barel like in times like these their
medical emergency kit is a must have the
wellness company is home to Dr Peter
Mulla Dr Drew Pinsky who was here in
studio just yesterday and truth-telling
doctors who are rooted in the the
commitment to build a parallel healthc
care system and Empower you to take
control of your health in a time when
over 40% of Americans say they would
avoid a doctor or Hospital unless it was
a catastrophic situation the wellness
company's medical emergency kit provides
a solution this handy little kit
includes eight potentially life-saving
medications for you to keep on hand
along with a guide book for safe use the
medical emergency kit includes emergency
antibiotics antivirals and anti
parasitics like amoxicillin zpac and ior
mecin to help keep you and your family
safe in the face of natural disasters
supply chain shortages or medical
emergencies like white lung or covid go
to tww c. rubben and grab your medical
emergency kit now and now back to me all
right so let's go into the sort of quote
unquote journalism portion of all of
this we've shown you kind of the
cultural and the TV portion the the
entertainment I guess you could call it
portion of this but what are they doing
in the news well of course they're
running cover for the Democrats and
trying to scare the hell out of you over
that orange man who is back uh George
Conway who is I suppose a
conservative like just one of these
nothing conservatives pet people they
give the cookie to show up on uh MSNBC
uh here's his analysis on what they
should do uh to get rid of Donald Trump
and of course he's talking to Jen saki
former White House spokesperson who then
became a journalist because that's how
I've said this for quite some time I'm
going to say it again make him crazy
he's already crazy if you point out the
things that he the reason why he is the
way he is the reason why he is this uh
pathological narcissist is because he's
deeply insecure he knows that he's a
fraud he knows he's not as smart as he
says he is he knows he's not as good as
he says he is he knows he's a rapist he
knows he's a liar he knows he doesn't
want to be Expos and if you attack him
on the things that he feels sensitive
about with the
truth he melts and he's exactly as you
say I mean he's a bully but he's a weak
man he's a weak okay I'm only showing
you that because these people that they
put on there they just offer them the
red meat right and then of course their
kind of brain damaged Progressive
audience eats it up it's interesting
though because there's this guy George
Conway who I think was one of the
founders of Lincoln project if I'm not
mistaken which originally was put out to
be an anti-trump thing and then it
became just an anti you know we were
we're the principal conservatives who
were against Trump and then it became an
anti-republican thing uh but it's
interesting because he calls him a
rapist there now Donald Trump has never
been convicted of rape even in this case
with egene Carol he's being convicted or
found guilty of defamation basically
making fun of her because of her rape
accusations so by that logic couldn't
Donald Trump now Sue George Conway for
calling him a rapist that seems like a
pretty bad thing to call somebody
although apparently if you're watching
Law and Order some chicks kind of dig it
uh anyway you get it the MSNBC it's all
a clown show and speaking of clown shows
the EJ Carol verdict comes out and the
ladies of the view were so excited about
it so excited that Donald Trump's gonna
have to pay 83 million or they're you
know they're going to try to stop this
thing in court further uh but 83 million
to this woman that they walked out on
The View to The Apprentice theme
song
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome to the view we just walked out
to The OJ's For the Love of Money which
is the theme song of The Apprentice and
that's connected to the fact that you
know who
has to pay money money money
money something like $83 million 83.3 oh
I'm sorry
83.3 it really it's so it's so horrible
and then watching the women applaud like
if they all felt that this woman really
got raped again rape is pretty bad uh
they wouldn't be celebrating today right
like it wouldn't be a day of Celebration
it would be kind of a somber like there
was a verdict in the defamation thing
related to the rape and Donald Trump's
going to have to pay up but they know
it's all it's all a show they
are clowns that's exactly what it is and
ejan Jean Caroll right now is making the
rounds on the media uh and she's they're
loving her because she's talking
about big Donald Trump and uh well here
she is on CNN with some of her plans
with that cash you may soon though have
quite a bit of his money and I I wonder
how you plan to use that oh it's
inspiring we talk about it a lot we're
going to do good with that money we're
going to do Mary Trump has suggested uh
we turn Trump Tower into an animal
sanctuary for
instance joke that was a joke poy uh no
but we're we're inspired to U do not
waste a penny of this and we have some
good ideas that we're working on
specifically aimed at what would oppose
Trump well Donald Trump
hates women remember the New York
Magazine the famous quote when they said
Don what do you think of women he said
women they're not worth a piece of crap
remember that quote and so I think one
of the things we could do seeing as how
he's very instrumental in taking away
women's rights over their bodies across
the United States maybe we can think
about how we can restore women their
rights use a little of money for that
okay Donald Trump has not taken any way
any woman's rights away right if you're
a woman watching this right now you have
the exact same rights post Donald Trump
that you had pre Donald Trump we can
talk about abortion and the right to
life and things of that nature but you
get it but the point is they're just
putting her on now she's going on all
the networks just to just like parade
the idea that Donald Trump is just
horrible he hates women we're going to
do all this good stuff with the money
again if she got raped which Donald
Trump was not convicted of would you
would you want to make a show of of all
of this Show Must Go On here's ejn
Carroll on with Rachel mattow serial
liar Rachel mattow with she expands on
some of the ideas for the cash you've
talked about using some of Trump's money
that you're about to get um to help
Shore up women's rights do you know what
that might be what that might look like
yes Rachel yes tell me I had such such
great ideas for all the good I'm going
to do with this money first thing Rachel
you and I are going to go shopping we're
going to get completely new wardrobes
new shoes motorcycle for crawling new
fishing rod for Robbie Rachel what do
you want Penthouse it's yours Rachel
Penthouse and uh France you want France
you want to go fishing in France no oh
all right all right okay that's a
joke although if if me fishing in France
could do something for women's rights I
would take the hit you know I would
obviously take one for the team all
right let me let
me fishing rod for this one and like
does this woman seem like she got raped
like wouldn't she be up there going you
know uh Rachel to be clear this was just
on the defamation thing and not the rape
thing and actually I really I'm going to
give all the money to I don't know
women's shelters to stop rape or like
we're going to go shopping and the F the
fishing rod did that woman that woman
she strike me as someone that likes to
go fishing but who the hell knows uh
anyway uh it continued here they are
discussing that maybe they can figure
out another way to sue the guy e in
terms of the um what you've just been
through I mean to hear a lawyer as
experienced as Robbie Kaplan say it was
nerve-wracking to be in that room
sometimes because of the way this was
conducted um I I have to ask you you
know president Trump has kept your name
out of his mouth since being told he has
to pay $83 million to you for what he's
done in the past but over the weekend he
did start post links online to articles
that attacked you and denied your claims
again he seems to be pushing it already
in terms of whether or not he is going
to go back to calling you a liar and
denying that he did what he did um if it
if it came to it if your lawyers told
you that there was another case and that
you should go back and get more money
out of him and sue him again would you
do it
absolutely
absolutely again uh just one more time
this is about a defamation win for her
not a rape win so even when Rachel M
says he's going after you for what he
saying with that what was it for he did
what he did right the implication is
that Rachel matow somehow knows that
Donald Trump actually in fact raped this
woman right there's just no evidence of
that and that's not what this whole
freaking trial was about it's just
absolutely insane uh here's one more of
uh e Gene Carol I promise you this is
the last one of eege Carol for now uh
describing Donald Trump
who by the way Rachel is not even there
he's
nothing he is without he is like a
walrus snorting and like a rhino
flopping his hand it was he is not there
that was the surprising thing to me did
you catch that she calls him a walrus
snorting and then the woman next to her
was
like what these are not real people is
this real is this real
um I'd like to connect this uh to a
wider situation as you know I'm wanted
to do uh my friend Megan Kelly had a
nice analysis of how this whole thing
has been playing out take a look found
it 51% more likely than not that he did
it uh based on that
51% they've declared him a sexual
pervert basically and they want us all
to go along with they want us all to say
it's horrible how Trump keeps dismissing
this woman as opposed to let's just
entertain for a minute the possibility
that Trump is the truth tell here that
Trump actually has no memory of this
person and certainly didn't sexually
assault her and that she really is some
sort of a c who decided to make up a
story about him to get her name in the
headlines to potentially get money from
a deep pocketed guy the media has zero
appetite for entertaining that
possibility and therefore they take
umage at his she's a wack job what's he
supposed to say if somebody came out
against you Glenn from when you know 20
years ago when you were 20 right You' be
like this person's a nutcase I don't
know them and so that's really what
Trump has been saying and for that now
he's going to have to pay almost $100
million okay so you really need to
understand this and this is why Megan is
just so consistently great I don't know
what happened you don't know what
happened Megan Kelly doesn't know what
happened I believe she was talking to to
Glenn Beck right Glenn Beck doesn't know
what happened the point is
that he was not convicted of rape he has
not subsequently said anything about her
but again as a if you're being sued for
defamation being called a rapist seems
kind of defaming right like that seems
like a problem so he Trump has not said
anything subsequently uh but we did want
to show you this this is kind of this is
funny Trump when he had to give the
deposition about what happened and the
accusations by EEG Carol uh this is
Trump about two years ago doing just
that when you said in that video that M
Leeds would not be your first choice you
were referring to her physical looks
correct just the overall not I look at
her I see her I hear what she says
whatever you wouldn't be a choice of
mine either to be honest with you I hope
you're not insulted I would not under
any circumstances have any interest in
you I'm being I'm honest when I say it
uh she I would not have any
interest
you I wouldn't rape you I wouldn't I'd
rape this one over here like like that's
the TR it's like it's insane and it's
crazy and it's funny and Looney and and
all of those things at once now the
reason I did all of that there and we
Dove so deep into the mind of Ean Carol
eege Carol uh is because I wanted to get
to that clip because that clip shows you
the sort of the craziness and Brilliance
of trump all at once like he actually is
saying something kind kind of honest
like I wouldn't rape a woman I'm not
attracted to like that there's something
sort of honest there and then it's also
kind of crazy but now I want to connect
that to something that's happening in
the world and show you Trump at his
absolute best uh because these are the
moments that uh we could use a real
leader in this country and I think he
has an interesting opportunity and as
I've been telling you for the last two
weeks I want to nudge him to be the best
Donald Trump if possible so you probably
heard that there was a drone strike in
the Middle East in Jordan uh three US
soldiers were killed Sergeant William J
Rivers uh special Sergeant Kennedy L
Sanders and Briana a mfet now
interestingly they all happen to be
black which is completely irrelevant uh
other than the media is not really
saying much about this story or adding
that racial element to it because it's
the Biden Administration that this is
happening under uh we've got some uh
specifics on it from the daily wire more
than 30 US soldiers were injured in an
attack us officials said on Sunday in
Jordan adding that they were positive
that the attack was carried out by
radical iran-backed militant groups
operating in Syria and Iraq us officials
said that the suicide drone evaded
detection by US forces because it
closely trailed a US drone that was
returning to the base at the same time
political reported the US military
released the identities of the three
soldiers who were murdered by an Iranian
back terrorist attack in the Middle East
over the weekend as well as the details
about how the attack unfolded Sergeant
William Dron Rivers 46 of Carolton
Georgia uh Kennedy Leiden Sanders 24 Way
Cross Georgia and Briana Alexandria
Mafia 23 of Savannah Georgia died on
January 28th 2024 in Jordan when a
one-way unmanned aerial system impacted
their container housing units the
Department of Defense said in a
statement so now you might be wondering
Dave what does this have to do with the
ejn Carol thing well Donald Trump issued
a statement on this uh and I think he
nailed it this this is what I tweeted
and then I'm going to read it to you
this is Trump at his best no non sense
Stark reality and I want to read it to
you because this is Trump at his best
and this is the Trump that we need if
we're going to turn this thing around
the Drone attack on a US military
installation in Jordan killing three
American Service members and wounding
many more marks a horrible day for
America my most profound sympathies go
to the families of the Brave service
members we have lost I asked all
Americans to join me in praying for
those who have been wounded this Brazen
attack on the United States is yet
another horrific and Tra IC consequence
of Joe Biden's weakness and surrender
three years ago Iran was weak broke and
totally under control thanks to my
maximum pressure policy the Iranian
regime could barely scrape together $2
to fund two $2 together to fund their
terrorist proxies then Joe Biden came in
and gave Iran billions of dollars which
the regime has used to spread Bloodshed
and Carnage throughout the Middle East
this attack never would have happened if
I was President not even a chance just
like the Iranian backed Hamas attack on
Israel would never have happened the war
in Ukraine would have never happened and
we would right now have peace throughout
the world instead we are on the brink of
World War II this terrible day is yet
more proof that we need an immediate
return to peace through strength so that
there will be no more chaos no more
destruction and no more loss of precious
American lives our country cannot
survive with Joe Biden as
commander-in-chief look I I don't know
if Donald Trump wrote that himself it's
obviously irrelevant they have speech
writers and everything else but the
clarity
the moral Clarity peace through strength
the reality of the fact that three four
years ago when Donald Trump was still
president it's a little more than that
now but when Donald Trump was still
president especially preco that the
world was peaceful and middle east peace
deals were being signed left and right
the Iranians were doing absolutely
nothing subsequently the Biden
Administration comes in we release all
of this money to the Iranians Weeks
Later Hamas does this insane attack in
Israel now we're watching virtually
every day our bases be attacked across
the Middle East I don't know what the
exact policy is that we're supposed to
do right now right like and I don't
think most people know exactly what
we're supposed to be doing and I I don't
think most people want World War III but
you don't you don't get peace through a
appeasement right ask Chamberlain how
that worked out when he was working with
Hitler oh wait well we'll just let
Hitler do a little bit of take a little
something that'll work out right you get
peace through strength right we this is
who we are this is what we stand for
we've got some weapons to back it up and
don't mess with us one of the first
things that Donald Trump did when he got
into office was drop the mother of all
bombs the M Moab the mother of all bombs
dropped it people didn't even know why
he dropped it but it made it seem like
he was kind of crazy so don't mess with
this guy he killed sulamani right and
everyone was like this is going to start
World War II actually it caused Iran to
not do much of anything while he was
President then you get this weak
president in right now and basically
everyone Putin why did Putin do nothing
with Ukraine under Donald Trump right he
took Crimea under Obama then Trump comes
in Putin goes all quiet even though they
said he would Trump was a Russian stooge
then Trump goes out Biden comes in boom
we have a war in Ukraine so you guys get
all that and and this is the type of
moral Clarity and and clear positioning
when it comes to our place in the world
that I think plays well to Trump so we
don't need the silly Trump right I know
he can't fully control it and I'm not
saying it's all terrible but we need the
good Trump because there are bad guys
out there and they seemingly are coming
for us anyway speaking of some of the
bad guys that are here in this country
uh diversity hire Karin Jean Pierre
yesterday said one of the this is one of
the stupidest things that has ever been
uttered by a representative of the White
House um well just listen for yourself
what I will say our deepest uh obviously
our deepest condolences uh go out and
our heartfelt condolences go out to the
families uh who lost uh three three
Brave uh three Brave uh three Brave of
three folks who are who are military
folks who are brave who are always
fighting who are fighting on behalf and
of uh this administration of the
American
people that is absolutely incredible do
you catch the end of that who are
fighting on behalf of this
Administration those people are not
Administration they are fighting on
behalf of the United States of America
which hope will survive this
Administration we'll see about that but
they are not fighting for the Biden
Administration they are fighting for the
United States of America for at least as
long as we remain United that's Al also
another issue just absolutely completely
ridiculous and it gets worse with her I
mean this woman is just she's she's in
some ways she's perfect like in one hand
you could watch her and be frustrated
and be like how did this woman get the
job and okay she's a black lesbian it's
so exciting it's just great on the other
hand she's the perfect embodiment of
everything that is wrong with this
Administration uh and uh she doesn't
seem to want to pressure the president
to call any of those military families
who just lost their children um has the
president uh called already or does he
plan to speak with the families of the
Fall service members um don't have any
calls to read out uh this is a a sad day
this yesterday was a very very sad day
no we don't we don't know we don't know
if he's going to call anybody right well
you know he's busy like the guy he's
always doing stuff he's just got so much
energy uh he just doesn't have time to
to call the servicemen it's just so so
evil but what's she really focused on
what's this Administration really really
focused on while Iran kills members of
our military yeah you guessed it science
is clear climate change isn't is the
existential threat of our time so yeah
it's climate change the climate is
coming the climate is coming and it's
going to make her hair flat when the
humidity Rises uh but it's not just her
this entire Administration is running
run by weak and or confused people right
it's it's a bunch of diversity hires who
are unqualified or people who just like
Anthony blinkin our secretary of state
and this clip is just another one it's
another one where you just watch it and
you're like did he actually just say
that listen to
this I would argue that we have not
seen a situation as as dangerous as the
one we're facing now across the region
since at least
1973 uh Anthony you're not supposed to
say that out loud because that emboldens
our enemies you might want to kind of
dial that back of course 1973 was the OM
Kipper War which uh then could have
burst much bigger uh into into the world
and fortunately it did not become a
world war but it does seem to me that
there's a lot of Tinder out there and
there's a lot of flames and things seem
to be catching fire uh so getting out
there and being like well this is this
is we're in a pretty horrible spot right
now especially when no one has
confidence that the president knows what
he's doing or that we have a cohesive
foreign policy or anything else anyway
this one is just wild so over on the
televised mental institution of MSNBC
yesterday Joy Reed blonde woman Joy Reed
uh they cut to Commercial and well
listen to what Joy Reed sounds like when
she doesn't think she's on camera over
the weekend President Biden said he's
ready to take action if Congress is
serious about solving the Border
issue if that bill were the law today
I'd shut down the border right now and
fix it quick and Congress needs to get
it done starting another
War oh did Joy Reed just say the quiet
part out loud that Joe Biden because
what's happening at the border and they
were also playing a clip of Iran earlier
that Joe Biden's about to start another
effing War you guys know I Love the
clips when these robots these
pre-programmed robots who are just paid
by the machine to spout nonsense when
they start breaking down and they
actually tell you the truth well they
came back from commercial and she uh
well she lied again on why she even said
that so I just wanted to apologize very
quickly uh I was chatting during a clip
that was playing um and you know we try
to keep this show very PG-13 so I just
want to apologize to anyone who is
listening to my behind the scenes
chatter uh deeply deeply apologize for
that because you know it's PG-13 up
around here so thank you to you all for
watching the read out and inside with J
saki start oh my God you know I was just
you know we didn't realize and that's
when I tell you the truth when we're
going to Commercial and I start with
other people there like think how revers
that is from what I do here I'm telling
you what I think you can agree you can
disagree you can love me for it you can
hate me for it but do you think like
when we throw to a clip that I'm turning
to them and being like here's how I
really feel about that like it's such
profound evil BS so what is the winning
strategy with all of this right when you
see them bringing back the old vestages
who got everything wrong like John
Stewart and then you see the way they
accidentally sometimes tell the truth
when they're cut into commercial like
what is the actual winning strategy well
the wi the winning strategy uh is I
think also the moral and rational
strategy which is partly at least when
it comes to what's going on with Iran
right now what Donald Trump did last
time peace through strength and people
start responding to that right people
understand just because you say that you
are a strong country it doesn't mean you
want to fight everybody it means oh you
will defend certain principles and we
better get back to that cuz whatever
we're doing here is kind of melting down
so otherwise otherwise you think Joe
Biden and you think kin jeanpierre and
Anthony blinkin and the rest of these
clown people you think they can get us
out of whatever mess is happening right
now between Russia and Iran and the rest
of it of course they can of course they
can and the beauty of all of that is
that especially because of what we've
been talking about the last couple days
uh which we'll get to more tomorrow this
border situation more and more people
are waking up the average apolitical
kind of default Lefty because the entire
cultural apparatus B basically um
replicates lefties that's what the
system creates lefties and then you have
to wake up at some point more and more
people are waking up because of that uh
this is Joe Rogan from his show this
week talking about how he has woken up
to the leftist lunacy over time this is
what we're seeing so over time you and I
who used to be on the left are now like
where's the left where are you guys you
guys are so far away I can't even see
you're out of your mind you're you're
chopping dicks off and and giving little
kids hormone blockers you have no idea
what the long-term consequences are
you're ignoring the health risks you
won't even talk about the health risks
you you use things like gender affirming
care what are you saying what are you
saying when you're talking about
children why are you just accepting this
cuz it's it's a noble thing to blurt out
so everybody goes you're on the right
team that's what it is it's not like oh
my God what are we doing to kids it's
not like oh my God what are we doing to
San Francisco it's not like oh my God
why are we letting these violent
criminals out of jail it's oh my God why
are we defunding the police what are you
doing yeah you can't say any of those
things you say any of those things
you're aning I I was 100% a left leaning
person who lived in Los Angeles I was
100% I never voted Republican my whole
life I was very left leaning especially
with like any social issues when it
comes to financial things I'm a little
bit more conservative but at the end of
the day I'm way more left than I am
right but California went nuts man it's
gone like full communist it's out of its
mind and their approach to law
enforcement is so insane it's so
insane why I left the left by Joe Rogan
um okay you get the point you get the
point who is closer to reality is it Joe
Rogan right there talking about the
lunacy of gender quote affirming care
and talking about the craziness of
letting all the criminals out on the
street of Cali or is it the guy we
started the show with who was Pro
chopping genitals off kids John Stewart
and who was running cover for the
governor of California Gavin Nome who
has destroyed that state so those the
lines are being drawn right now what I
would love to see out of Joe Rogan is
finally say it man I get it you didn't
have the balls to to support Trump last
time okay fine will you do it this time
and I say that as someone that wasn't
even supporting Trump a couple weeks ago
but it is pretty damn obvious where
things are at right now so everyone is
going to have to take aide and everyone
is going to have to call balls and
Strikes honestly and well no the best
way to go about doing things would be to
call balls and Strikes honestly and and
then let the chips fall where they may I
get that not everyone will do that uh
but be brave and and fight fight fight
man because between the border between
Iran between the chopping of the kids
genitals it's an awful lot and uh
there's got to be a way out of this
thing so that's all I have to say about
that uh people of the internet's live at
1: p.m. post post game show coming up in
30 seconds at Ruben report. locals.com
oh and we have a great cold close for
you yesterday I want to credit Brock for
putting this together we have I've been
sitting on this old uh Justice League
little clip Legion of Doom clip for a
while I had this idea and then you know
over the last couple days there's been
this whole thing with unra which is the
UN organization that basically is
supposed to deal with the Palestinians
and it's turned out that they were just
like funding the terrorists and that
many of their un employees actually were
Hamas members and a whole bunch more so
put this together and I I just love it
we'll see you on the other side ciao the
Legion of Doom is now in session it is
the purpose of the Legion to align our
Infamous forces against the powers of
good and defeat them leaving us the
rulers of the world to do this we have
gathered together the 13 most ruthless
villains on Earth the bridgid captain
coold the Sinister mind of
[Music]
Sinestro the awesome Bizarro and Solomon
Grundy the cunning cheetah and the super
intelligent computer Android
Brainiac Black Manta and Gro the
gorilla the toy man and the humorous but
Sinister Riddler
[Music]
the feminine yet ferocious
giganta and the Hideous
[Music]
scarecrow not to mention the Evil Genius
and Brilliant leadership of myself Le
[Music]
Luthor